in an October 10th article in USA Today
Donald Trump wrote that quote if
Democrats win control of Congress this
November we will come dangerously close
to socialism in America
end quote are Americans embracing
socialism in an August Fox News poll 36
percent of registered voters said it
would be a good thing for the United
States to move away from capitalism and
more toward socialism
well 51 percent said it would be a bad
thing this summer
Gallup also asked people about their
views of socialism and 37 percent said
they had a positive view while 58
percent had a negative one in the
September 2018
NBC News Wall Street Journal poll 19
percent had a positive view of socialism
52 percent said they had a negative view
and 26 percent a neutral one in all of
these polls Democrats were more positive
about socialism than Republicans and
young people more so than older ones
overall though Americans aren't
embracing socialism do you think
socialism would work in America let us
know in your comments and also let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI